ONE GAME BY
RASMUS ANDERSSON.
IN?K TO JUSTIN FAULK,
>> Harnarayan: TIPPED BY ROBERT
BY HUSSO, THE
IDEA RIGHT THROUGH THE MIDDLE OF
THE ICE.E BEHIND THE NET,
WASN'T ABLE TO CATCH UP TO THE
PUCK.
NOW ZADOROV DOES, ZADOROV MOVING
TRYING TO FORCE IT IN THERE IS
LINDHOLM, BUT HE JUSTIT.
LEFT IT THERE FORLUES ARE BACK
THE NEUTRAL ZONE BY BACKLUND.
IN.
SCHENN PASS TOEILLY TAKES ADVAN
TO GIVE THE BLUES A
EVERYBODY, LINDHOLM, DOESN'T
MISS THAT VERY OFTEN, BUT IT'S
JOHNNY GAUDREAU BACK TO TKACHUK.
GAUDR
AS LINDHOLM JUST HE FEEDS THE P
AND IT'S IN! STARTING
THIS PLAY AND A GOAL!
IT'S WALKER!
THE RIFIFSCHENN,
FINAL 60 SECONDS.
A SHOT ON NET, AND THE BLUES  T
HUSSO SHANGLE.
DUBE KNOCKS ITS
BLOCKED.
OPEN NET, AND NOW
>> Harnarayan: BRANDON SAAD